مشاهدينا نحييكم في هذه النافذه للتحليل
العسكري للمجريات الميدانيه لحرب اسرائيل
على قطاع غزه وكالعاده نستضيف المحلل
العسكري اللواء فايز دويري مرحبا بك سيد
فايز اي في البدايه ايضا ننتقل مباشره
لنتابع سير العمليات العسكريه في قطاع غزه
ومختلف المحاور عبر الخريطه التفاعليه مع
سلام خضر سلام شكرا حسن سنبدا ا في هذه
الخريطه التفاعليه من حيث
انتهى الفيديو الذي شاهدناه لكتائب عز
الدين القسام من شمال منطقه من شمال قطاع
غزه لسببين الاول لان الفيديو الذي بثته
القسام يظهر حجم الاشتباكات العنيفه التي
لا تزال تدور في مناطق شمال قطاع غزه
المسافات قريبه جدا والاسلحه المستخدمه
متنوعه هناك استهدافات بصواريخ محموله على
الكتف او قذائف مضاده للدروع وايضا هناك
مشكله ال عبوات التي ما زالت كتائب القسام
تستخدمها وقال قبلها قبل يومين قال دانييل
هاجار المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي ان
هذه العبوات والافخاذ هي العائق الاساسي
امام تحرك الجنود الاسرائيليين ايضا قبل
قليل وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي تحدث عن ان
المنطقه الشماليه برمتها برمتها المنطقه
الشماليه سيجري فيها الجيش الاسرائيلي
عمليات بريه وجويه وايضا ينفذ عمليات خاصه
هذا هو الواقع الان ما تحدث به جالنت يقوم
به حاليا الجيش الاسرائيلي ينفذ طلعات
جويه ايضا يستخدم المدافع لضرب عدد من
الاماكن داخل القطاع وبطبيعه الحال هناك
توغلات بريه ينفذها اليوم على سبيل المثال
اكثر من منطقه شهدت توغلات اسرائيليه في
الشمال رغم ان الجيش الاسرائيلي هو قال
بنفسه بانه انسحب وانهى هذه العمليات
اليوم عاد ليتوغل وايضا عاد
ليتمكنا قرب ساحل مدينه غزه في شمال
القطاع
والاشتباكات ما زالت مستمره في شمال مدينه
غزه في هذه الاحياء وال هناك عده عمليات
نفذت في هذه المنطقه من قبل كتائب القسام
وهناك عمليات مشتركه بين القسام وسرايا
القدس وهذه العمليات ايضا موجوده في
المنطقه الوسطى المنطقه الوسطى اليوم كانت
في
صلب القتال العنيف والضاري بحسب الطرفين
نحن نتحدث عن
هذا المربع ان صيرات البريج المغازي
والزوايده الجيش الاسرائيلي منذ عده ايام
وهو يطوق مخيم البريج يحاول اختراق البريج
يتوغل قليلا ثم يتراجع نتيجه الضربات
ضربات المقاومه ويحاول ايضا ان يتقدم اليه
من ناحيه الغرب اليوم قطع شارع صلاح الدين
وفصل بين نصيرات وبين المغازي انسرات طبعا
يتعرض ايضا لغارات جويه وكذلك المغازي
وهناك هجوم اليوم محاوله دخول الى منطقه
النصيرات واستهداف لدير البلح التي قال
قبل عده ايام او طلب من السكان وسط غزه
التوجه اليها بوصفها امنه استهدفت بشكل
عنيف وهناك ضحايا سقطوا اليوم نعود الى
الجنوب وهي المنطقه التي اشتعلت بشكل
متاخر عن باقي مناطق القطاع خانون
تونس حاوطها الجيش الاسرائيلي وقاتل عند
تخومها لعده اسابيع شهد مقاومه شرسه من
القسام وباقي فصائل المقاومه اليوم تمكن
او يعني اليوم هي احدى الايام التي دخل
فيها دخلت فيها الاليات الاسرائيليه الى
داخل مدينه خان يونس وطبعا هناك مقاومه
وهناك اشتباكات يضطر احيانا الى سحب
الياته خارج المدينه مع عوده الى التوغ
طبيعه خان يونس كما يبدو لا تسمح باقامه
تحصينات تعطي امان للدبابات والاليات
والافراد بشكل خاص خانيونس تعمل فيه سبع
الويه احدها هو لواء يا هالوم المتخصص
بتفكيك الالغام والانفاق ولهذا ربما نفهم
ماذا ماذا يجري في خزاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي
بحسب شهادات من المنطقه يقوم بتفخيخ ابنيه
وا اماكن ومنشات
ويفجرها يقول انه يبحث عن مراكز قياده
تابعه لحركات المقاومه للقسام تحديدا حسن
بموازاه هذه التطورات هناك قراءه وهناك
مواقف اخرى نتابعها مع نعم هناك قراءه
ايضا لمشاهد
اي الاشتباكات في مدينه خانيونس لكن قبل
ذلك سنحاول ان نقرا في التطورات الميدانيه
التي ذكرتيها مع اللواء فايز الدويري سيد
فايز باختصار منطقه الشمال كما هو واضح
تدخل قوات الاحتلال في منطقه ثم تخرج ثم
تدخل مره ثانيه بمعنى ان اعاده التموضع
ليست ثابته في مناطق الشمال دعنا نقسم ما
يجري في الشمال الى قسمين رئيسيين اي
المنطقه الشرقيه عندما نتحدث عن جبل
الرئيس الشعف اجزاء من الشجاعيه الدرج
التف تفاح هذه المنطقه لو ظللتها هذه
المنطقه لا تزال المعارك تجري فيها لا
تزال المعارك جاريه على مدار ال 24 ساعه
نعم اجبر اؤكد اجبر على التراجع من التفاح
والدرج ومن الشعف بدرجه كبيره جدا لم
يستطع التثبت دفع ثم ثمن باهظ جدا
والفيديوهات كانت هي التي تجسد الواقع
لماذا لانه مقاربه
ال القسام وبقيه الفصائل كان فيها نوع من
الاختلاف طيب اعتمدت نظام القتال في
مجموعات وعمليات نصب الكمائن
والاستدراج المنطقه الوحيده التي دعنا
نقول لا يزال يحاول ان يتقدم ويتراجع
المناطق الاخرى يجبر على التراجع اللي هي
منطقه جبل الرئيس المناطق التي اخلاه ثم
يعود ال هم ثم يعود هذه تندفع كما اشارت
الان تندفع الاليات بيكون تم الحصول على
معلومه معينه وبالتالي يتم التعامل معها
وهذه هي التحول التدريجي للمرحله الثالثه
اقول التحول التدريجي لانه سيخسر المطقه
جبل الريس التي وبقايا ما يجري من قتال
ومن ثم سينك فيئ واعتقد ان الكفاء
الانكفاء لن يكون مباشرا الى الغلاف نعم
سيكون م مرحلا وبالتالي
سيستقر خارج ال خارج اي قطاع عمليا كان
الجيش الاسرائيلي بدا فعليا
بعمليات المرحله الثالثه قبل ان يعلن عنها
رسميا نعم في المنطقه الشماليه تحديدا
تحديدا لو انتقلنا الى الوسط الى الوسط
المغازي النصيرات والبريج هناك معارك
عنيفه سي تجري في هذه الم اقصى المعارك
الان تجري في هذه المنطقه هذه المنطقه تم
حشد الفرقه 36 المدرعه تم دعمها بلوائي
مظليين وتم دعمها ببعض الكتائب كتائب
كتيبه مشا وكتيبه
استطلاع لا اود الحديث لما ذكرته سابقا
ساتحدث عما يجري الان اليوم الان هو
استطاع ان يدخل مع شارع صلاح الدين ويستغل
المسافه البينيه الفاصله ما بين البريج
والسيارت طور هجومه على البريج من ثلاثه
اتجاهات من الشمال من الشرق ومن الغرب
في المنطقه المنطقه الفاصله ما بين البريج
والنصيرات ودخل بال الاتجاه الاخر هذه
المنطقه هذه المنطقه يوجد فيها لوائين
لواء مدرع ولواء مظليين دفع
اعاد تشكيل القوه القتاليه بحيث جعل كتيبه
مظليين مدعومه
كتيبه لواء دروع مدعوما الان لوائين كل
لواء ثلاث كتائب ثلاث كتائب فهناك ست
كتائب الان ثلاث كتائب تم خلطها المظليين
مع القوات الدروع من اجل تامين الحمايه
وبدا الان الضغط عمل عمليه مناوره التفاف
الى الشمال الغربي من الصيرات من اجل ان
يجبر القوات
على دعم المنطقه الشماليه لانه المنطقه
الشماليه تعتبر نقطه ضعيفه لماذا ياتيها
من ال المغرا ويمكن ان ياتيها من البحر
وبالتالي يصبح ما بين فكي كماشه فبالتالي
حتى يجبر القوات ل الانكفاء ويزيد من
الفتحه الواقعه بين البريج والنصيرات تخطى
كذلك الى منطقه الزوايده وبدا يهاجم في
المغازي لكن حتى هذه اللحظه لا تزال
الكتائب قادره على خوض معركه دفاعيه ناجحه
طيب قبل ان ننتقل الى المشاهد المصوره فقط
بكلمتين وباختصار ما يجري في خان يونس في
خان يونس الان
القتال في منطقه شرق خان يونس في عبسان
الجديده بن السيلا عبسان الكبيره من الزنه
حتى خزاعه هذه المنطقه لم يستطع الدخول
بها على شكل حرف في يعني ينتهي في منطقه
في منطقه غرب بن سيلا خان يونس
ولكن اخذ دخل الجزء الشمالي من شمال عبسان
الجديده والزن ودخل ال من اطراف خزاعه
باتجاه الفخاري ولكن المنطقه عبسان
الكبيره وعبس وبني السير لم يستطع الدخول
بها وهناك قتال وحت طريقه القتال يوجد على
نظاق من الانساق النسق الاول خمسه الويه
والنسق الثاني لوائين اللي بيتعاملوا واحد
منهم في منطقه خزاعه بقيت نقطه
مهمه اشير لها بعجاله منطقه القراره هذه
المنطقه في في هذا اليوم تتعرض لجهود
لهجوم من ثلاثه اتجاهات نعم من الغرب ومن
الشمال ومن الشرق
وبحجم اكثر من لواء ونص لوائين ناقص
مختلطه
وتم اسناد هذه القوه
بمجموعات من قوات النخبه لواء جفعاتي الذي
اخرج في ال منه الكتيبه 13 تم اعاده
والزج به في منطقه بني سهيله طيب كنا
نتحدث عن الوسط كنا نتحدث ايضا عن مدينه
غزه
سنشاهد واياك هذه الصور والمشاهد
للفيديو التي الذي حصلت عليه الجزيره
لمعارك واستهداف واشتباكات في محاور مدينه
غزه ثم
نحلله يا
انزل انزل
[موسيقى]
انزل هذه هنا دبابه المركا دبابه
الميركافا
الشيء اللافت اولا تم استهداف
هدفين قريبين من بعضهما من قبل رما عدد
اثنين هذين هذان هما الهدفان الرام الاول
الدبابتين
تم استهدافهم من نفس المكان
تقريبا وتم تدمير الهدف الاول والرامي
الثاني قام بالتعامل مع الهدف الثاني فتم
تدمير الدبابتين بفارق زمني ها هو يقاس
بالثواني
نعم هذا الان دبابه في منطقه خلفيه من
منطقه مفتوحه السؤال الان من اين اتى هذا
المقاتل هذه منطقه تجمع اليات انظر عدد
الدبابات انظر قد يظهر لنا الان مجموعه من
الجنود على ظهر دبابه اربعه جنود انا
شاهدتهم على البطيء اربعه جنود كيف خرج
هذا واصبح على مقربه من منطقه
تجمع هذا السؤال انا اطرحه لجيب عنه
اوجهها ببساطه شبكه الانفاق بسم الله منها
انفاق دفاعيه وانفاق هجوميه شبكه الانفاق
الهجوميه لا تزال فاعله بحيث استطاع
الخروج منها
والوصول الى وهو ماذا استخدم استخدم حشوه
ضد الافراد لم يستخدم قاذر هذه الحشوه
تختلف من من حشوه الى اخرى ايه انما مصممه
بطريقه تحتوي مقدمه المتفجرات على مواد
معدنيه كرات وبراغي ومسامير
تعطي عندما تنطلق تنطلق بزاويه مفتوحه يصل
مداها الى 100 متر طولا و40 متر
عرضا وهذه صممت على غرار بعض انواع
الالغام الامريكيه وال هذ عبوه مضاده
للافرا هذه نفس العبوه اللي اتحدث عنها
نعم
طيب كنت كنت تشير او تسال من اين
جاء هذا المقاتل من كتائب القسام بوجود
هذا العدد من تجمع الاليات لكن هناك سؤال
ايضا في المقابل يطرح كيف لقوات الاحتلال
ان تتخذ منطقه لتجميع الاليات بهذا الشكل
والافراد بهذه الصوره وهي ليست مؤمنه
بالكامل هي تعتقد انها مؤمنه وا لنعود الى
احد الفيديوهات
القديمه احد الفيديوهات القديمه عندما خرج
المقاتل من النفق وكانت الدبابه على مسافه
اقل من 10 امتار نعم وكان
يحمل حشوه الشواظ الصقها على
الدبابه سحب الاسلاك نشطها وكان معه
تقريبا اربع ثواني ليفز داخل النفق اذا
فتحه النفق كانت على مسافه 10 متر هذه هي
الانفاق الهجوميه وبالتالي هذا العدو لم
لم يكشف شيء مهما قال والان هو زج في
منطقه الجنوب زجه بكتيبه الهندسه التي تم
اعدادها اصلا للتعامل مع الانفاق هو
اللافت ان الامر عمليا يعتبر خلف خلف خطوط
العدو نعم هو
هذا هو تنفيذ عمليات في دعنا
لنقول عمليات في العمق نعم الان عندما
نقول العمق الق قوات جيش الاحتلال دخل
دخلت الى منطقه معينه وكم مقدمه قوات
وهناك تموضع اليه تموضع معينه لكن هذه هذه
المنطقه يفترض انه دخلها في اليوم الاول
هذا مر عليها 67 يوم امم وهي القوات
تتواجد
فيها وبعد بعد 67 يوم يخرج وينفذ المهمه
اي من جديد لانه فاتتنا بعض المشاهد التي
لم نعلق عليها من جديد هذه المشاهد تحدثنا
عنها الرامي الاول والرامي الثاني
والهدف بفارق ثوان ثواني نعم ه هذا المشهد
تم
شرحه وهذا ايضا لاحظ هذا خرج من منطقه
مكشوفه نعم خرج من منطقه مكشوفه الان ها
ها هو
يسدد هذه منطقه زراعيه
صحيح ه الجنود على ظهر الدبابه هنا تم
استخف استهدافهم ب
الحشوه حشوه ضد الافراد وليس بقاذف انت
لاحظ اليات مقدسه واقفه واليات متحركه
يعني هذا المكان في في حياه مش بس هذه
العبوه الم هذه العبوه الان هم بسموها
الرعديه التلفزيونيه هذه مسميات لها
اسبابها واضافه الى ذلك حصل اطلاق نار لا
هذ هذه نقطه شكرا على اثارتها عندما يتم
في معظم الحالات
استخدام تي بي جي او الحشوات
هذه هي ل لن لن تقتل او تصيب كل الموجودين
انما تبث في البدايه تحدث خسائر وتحدث
حاله من الرعب فبالتالي وبالتالي يبدا
يتحرك بصوره غير منتظمه غير مدروسه فيكون
هدفا سهلا لمساند الذي
نفذه مما يثبت ذلك اثناء التوضيع مساعده
كان يقول له وجه الحشوه وجه الحشوه هذه
ايضا كما ذكرنا نفس العبوه المضاده
للافراد
نعم هذه طبعا الحجم مختلف ممكن تكون فيها
باوند اث باوند 5 باوند حسب التصميم اللي
رتيه وحسب طبيعه الهدف اللي بدك تهاجمه
انما بتعطيك كما قلت لك يعني عرض بتغطي
منطقه عرضها الماكسيمم في الخط النهائي 40
متر و عمق 100 متر شكرا جزيلا لك اللواء
فيز الدويري على هذه الاطلاله التحليليه
ونشكر المشاهدين على هذه المتابعه ونعود
الان الى عبد السلام